you've been on the show before you were
here promoting Apollo 13 once you came
on the program and I think I really
helped that picture out with getting the
word out in failure your key to every
marketing strategy in Hollywood I really
you also and you were very much involved
in the from the from the earth to the
moon series HBO when did this passion
for space begin were you when you were
you passionate about this when you were
young well yeah I was because I just
thought it was very very cool and
glamorous to do things like go into
outer space and like do a spacewalk
there's so much so much so I we had a
now in the West Coast we had these
things called Doughboy pools you'd call
them an above-ground pool here on the
East Coast
mm-hm but Doughboy made them so there
was always like it was a it always a
aluminum with a liner in it you fill up
with water and about three weeks later
the bug start growing in it but for
three weeks you would actually swim in
it like it's a swimming pool I I would
go out and and have my own simulated
spacewalks in the Doughboy pool how does
that work well what you do you get you
wear baggy shorts cut-offs
and you put a brick right in the back in
the back of your butt so that will hold
you on the bottom of the of the pool but
all your limbs will then float up like
this uh-huh and in order to breathe in
order to breathe they get a garden hose
and you put it on the side and you stick
the garden hose in your mouth
I would wear a pair of like literally
you get him from my bin pranks and cost
like $0.99 swimming goggles uh-huh that
was this a hard rubber with with a
plated plaque plastic on and I sit there
and under three feet the pressure
actually pushes that against your face
so I'd be down there with this thing on
my face and a garden hose in my mouth
and I would be pretending to walk in
space there's a word for that guy well
not head not head yeah it was time for
dinner cuz my mom would say Larry go get
your brother out of the pool out of his
space walk it's time for dinner and he
would go out there and essentially get
the garden hose put a crimp in it is
very hard to get a brick out of your
pants when you're fighting for your life
would be the worst
god forbid something happened to you
that'd be the most embarrassing way to
go it would be bad but what a what a
hilarious little snippet of newspaper
you'd have to put on we see this from
the Red Bluff Daily News child drowns
with brick and bottom I can't tell you
will be a Jay Leno clip
and I can't tell you how many hours I
spent at the bottom of the pool like I
think like comic books in there would
just sit there and read because I just
love this is the freefall of their
nature
now were you into science fiction did
you like for example did you like Star
Trek oh yeah I set the clock by Star
Trek that was on at 6 o'clock on channel
2 in Oakland and yeah I much like you
know like when you meet like say you
like the Beatles or you meet the would
you get famous you'd be I like the the
baseball team you like sort of collect
the moments when you meet when you meet
the people yeah yeah it's a big deal and
I've met I saw Jimmy Doohan who played
Scotty thank you very much I saw him on
on in a play in San Francisco in 1975
using a play called the trial of James
McNeill Whistler and we're actually in
the audience why can't you think he has
a tricorder in his dressing room you
know but I met Leonard Nimoy and I met
two I've worked with Bill Shatner for
some Shakespeare benefits you know Bill
Shatner takes some heat sometimes from
the other you know Star Trek or from the
Trekkies sometimes they think it's all
gone to his head or that he's difficult
dude he played James Kirk yeah he was
the captain of the Starship Enterprise
you know I didn't see I didn't see Sulu
down on that planet making a cannon out
of bamboo to kill that dinosaur yeah he
didn't see is he like check off like
outwitting the gamesters of Triskelion
that was James Tiberius Kirk it was in
fact the narrator of the whole show
right you're right these are the voyages
of the Starship Enterprise
can you imagine the bones McCoy had
narrator that show I'm just a simple
country with my life forms of my little
whirling salt shaker that helps me
what's wrong with people now did you
ever meet Sulu did you meet Sulu I don't
think I've ever met George Takei George
Takei barrage DK really I talked to him
on the phone wouldn't you love to have
his pipes I I called him up because
voice way down here dogs like that and I
called him up because we want him to do
a voice on The Simpsons and I I called
him up and he just was like no I'm not
doing it it makes fun of monorails and
I'm in charge of transportation in San
Francisco's who screw yourself you're
such a big shot everybody's gonna drop
what they're doing and come do you a
favor I know this is this was 12 years
ago sorry he got a life while you're
still in show business
everything I said so far wrong I'm still
bad so much anger towards Sulu I wanted
to work it out using your valuable time
you've got things to do international
movie star and I'm like no we gotta talk
about Zulu and hello screwed me listen
guys I still got all about that guy with
that big ear that saying come to Eden
brother I he he still gives me the
willies dude don't say it don't say it
yeah yeah bad dreams oh so suddenly
you're too important to like that guy
I'm sorry I mean about is fair play
exactly turnabout is fair play